what we've been trying to do is send a
strong signal Brian of deterrence to any
other actor in the region be that a
nation state or a terrorist group that
now is not the time to think about
widening and escalating deepening this
conflict that there have been additional
attacks on our troops doesn't
necessarily mean that the war is
widening all right when Kirby says
additional attacks on our troops
overseas he means there have been 40 40
total attacks in the last 3 weeks alone
but the vam min ation is sending a
strong message of deterrence how does
that work joining me now as Richard
Goldberg former director for countering
Iranian weapons of mass destruction at
the NSC under Trump Richard um we have
threats um tonight from the second in
command of Hezbollah saying they're you
know they're waging their own uh attacks
and alliances of attacks to take the
pressure off of Gaza they call it the
the Agents of resistance that's
happening uh and now the White House's
comments how is this message being
received well I disagree with Mr Kirby
obviously we're not sending messages of
deterrence were sending messages of
appeasement here's what the White House
hasn't done they haven't ended their
nuclear deal with Iran that they cut
over the summer they haven't shut down
the bank accounts that they opened over
the summer10 billion out of Iraq they
haven't stopped the oil flow that's been
going to China that they've been
allowing they haven't snap back the UN
resolution to bring back sanctions uh on
Iran what have they done they've brought
in a new carrier strike group it's now
going to the Persian Gulf on its way
almost there but remember deterrence is
two things capability and will the
president is amassing a lot of military
capability in the region but he has not
shown the Iranians any will to actually
use that capability and therefore he is
failing to restore deterrence well
Richard uh President Biden is asking
Netanyahu for a brief 3-day they're not
calling a ceasefire they call it a pause
to to make themselves feel better so
they could release more hostages
Netanyahu reportedly rejected the idea
and said he doesn't trust Hamas and it
sounds like to me that Biden is
listening to the political uh
conversation in the streets and the
pressure being brought to bear against
the White House over the weekend your
thoughts on the pause
suggestion well remember this is the
same White House that brokered a hostage
deal paying $6 billion for five people
who brokered that hostage deal cut
who's brokering this hostage deal Qatar
who Harbors Hamas and is the sponsor of
Hamas Qatar what are we doing here of
course this is going to be a hostage
negotiation in hamas's favor and so you
know what there's 240 hostages let's not
talk about a ceasefire to let Hamas live
to Massacre another day for 12 people
let's talk about unconditional release
of 240 people or we start putting
maximum pressure on
Qatar well apparently they're not
worried about guitar they're worried
about politics back home Richard thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else